happy Friday Friday it's here this is
the unofficial game of thrones future
game of crowns challenge and joining me
today in the boot in the hot box today's
Matthew and Cena what is up Matthew whoa
we're not hot boxing in here but kind of
warm a term Aaron would know they are
okay and then joining us as always is
Aaron and Ricki Aaron's on the edit
Ricky's reading your comments on YouTube
and Duel Academy
how you guys doing yeah you guys look
very collegiate today gentlemen
we're trying to be professional that's a
professional Liberty's trying caps on
okay I want to give you guys a little
warning up front today we're gonna go
pretty deep on this not only are we
going to review the work that was
submitted kind of our top 50 and then
we're gonna narrow it down to our top
five there will be a drumroll probably
and we're actually going to get on the
box it's been a little while since we've
done this you guys have been asking for
it let's see if you really want this
because we're gonna do it okay so fasten
your seat belts guys it's gonna be a
long one for today so let's get learning
okay
the three-part design challenge as a
quick review in case you haven't seen
the original design challenge it looks
something like this there's part one
where we're asking you to design a sigil
which is an emblem or a coat of arms for
a house a great house from the house of
Westeros right and here are the
different houses let's go down the list
House Stark Lannister Targaryen
Baratheon Tyrell Greyjoy Tully Aran and
Martell those are the great houses okay
so I already mentioned what's the signal
they look something like this and you if
you think about it in the context of the
show itself if they're armies marching
on a battlefield and you have multiple
houses it's really really important that
we're able to recognize each house
really quickly because I don't want to
kill the wrong team you need to know
that so colors help bold graphics and
being able to read something from far
away really really help alright here the
details to the original challenge part
part one which is I gave you guys a
shape a crest to fit your design into
and I don't know if you figured it out
but the ones who filled out that shape
the best
probably stood to have an advantage
mm-hmm so if you get really detailed and
borders and all that kind of stuff yeah
might not work as well okay so here are
some other details that is that needed
to be black and white you're gonna use
up to three colors and definitely no
gradients I should have mentioned this
but I didn't really want anybody to do
any Photoshop work with textures and
anything like that that was implied in
the gradients but I wasn't clear but
that's totally okay things that we're
looking for Matthew myself is it legible
is it unique does it feel appropriate to
the house and last but not least is it
bold okay so the 50 most liked designs
move on to the judges top five so each
round you the audience will be empowered
once again it's like The Voice TV show
when we pick the final se but you get to
determine the winner
this way it's super democratic you take
a turn we take a turn and you take the
final turn so each round we're gonna
award points to the top five finalists
and we're also gonna give extra points
to the winner of that challenge so why
did I say this because as there's parts
two and three to the challenge we'll
assign points and so the person with the
most points at the end of this will win
some Goods some goods I mean it's not a
great package but it's our package we'll
work on a shoestring budget over here no
it's a great package so here we go all
right your work here we go without
further ado for a house Baratheon here
are the ones that we picked out as or I
guess with your help the top 50 and went
cold it down a little bit because it's a
little bit too much reef review 50 and
as we go along the way we'll talk about
it a little bit house baratheon their
symbol is a stag a male deer I believe
that's what a stag is right mmm the stag
so it's got its horns
I don't what they're called antlers rack
or something like that and here we go
ooh and house Baratheon currently
spoiler alert okay
no no currently I mean but the beginning
of the story House Baratheon is running
Westeros there it's the king the king of
all the kingdoms okay so here's number
one matthews catch up still yeah 1005
season five okay and you guys don't need
to have watched the series in in most
cases if you design an airline you don't
have to own the airline you don't even
have to have flown in the air
you just need to do proper research and
you figure out things that are
appropriate for that house mm-hmm
anyways this one I think was voted in
because it has a really cool H look
mm-hmm this shows me that this person
really knows that it looks straight and
it's got some really nice line work in
there Matthew yeah it's very ornate I
love the use of the space in there how
this person had taken advantage of the
shape of the crest there and then you
write like all the little ornate details
almost look like woodblock illustration
or etching and they're just it drew my
eye so from afar it already had a bold
shape and then as I look in you know it
had some interesting details to pick up
art yes and as we were reviewing many of
the submissions it's kind of hard to
nail the head of the deer from the front
position it's like what does it deer
look like right mm-hmm and obviously
when we see the antlers we know what it
looks like but I what I also like about
this particular execution is it has a
crown on it because they're the current
kings of the land in terms of the
storyline okay mm-hmm
so I think that's kind of nice that
Lillian Figueroa aka at the Kuban at
Cuba nerd did this so good job Lillian
let's keep moving on and Ricky you're
monitoring the comments live on our
Channel right and doing annotations the
annotation so let me know how many
people are tuning in right now Ricky
1:26 see we can't have this grow by the
end of the stream it's not just us
announcing the winners it's also us
doing some design work
we've picked two marks to kind of just
work on top up to hopefully provide you
some insight into what we would have
done okay so we need these we need the
audience to share this stream a little
bit we yeah to get that you know design
community go get it going okay so here's
another submission this is slide 18 this
one looks really good it's got a really
nice distinctive silhouette the deer is
kind of looking over its shoulder like
what's up man what's up with you it's
got a really interesting interpretation
of the antlers - it's a little bit more
organic and I like it
kind of like looks like coral or
something like oh I didn't yeah I didn't
see that I just was thinking like tree
branches or something like that right it
looks really dope and and still within
the confines of the
design challenge only two colors right
mm-hmm red and yellow I suppose I guess
black you can count as not a color and I
also like it that implies dimensionality
it's hard to have a mark like this and
make it feel like it's not totally flat
mm-hmm so the deer turning its head with
a little highlight underneath underneath
its neck is really nice there's some
little subtleties here in terms of the
nose and the way the ears pointed down
and the eyes it looks really really good
right I'm not good I think one note to
say on the horns what I like about it
too is that it feels a little bit more
aggressive because of the shape mmm so
you know these things are things that I
read into if I'm an enemy on the
battlefield and I saw Rose you know
house Tyrell and the other side I'm like
yeah but if I see this it's like oh my
gosh these guys they're killers back yes
that back like they look they look
aggressive so I like that so and I think
that's something that's really important
if you're gonna be one of the Great
Houses any vestigial it's like you know
Martel is it the house Martell with
roses yes it's like Tyrell Tyrell is
roses like okay but I think you want to
have a little edge to it so I like this
a lot right okay good job this is from
Jessica
Lionel or Leonel and she's at Leonel
designs or Lionel designs beautiful okay
next up look at this one Matthew this
one's super graphic and I like this one
a lot because of a couple different
reasons one is they utilize as much of
the shield crest emblem shape as
possible so this is tricky to get the
legs to kind of fit that shape it's
really nice and I also like and this is
a very unusual way of treating the
antlers that it almost looks like a saw
blade or something like that right like
it's also gonna cut you and it's one of
the most unique interpretations of the
antlers that we saw right and it it's
still flat yet it has a lot of
dimensionality right the the horns the
way that they're Illustrated there
implies an angle yet the way that the
the profile is and the body is it it's
totally flat so there's something very
unique going on and then the subtle
details of the back leg kind of breaking
out with the yellow line breaking up the
back leg these are nice little things
that add dimensionality even though this
is inherently 2d so
that this also you know it just was just
very dynamic and how it use the
limitations of what might be possible
for this decision I also like that of
the marks that we've seen so far this is
the first full body house baratheon that
we've seen of a stag right and the way
that the legs were moving it feels like
it's prancing so there's a little bit of
a strut like you know hey we the King
step off right got this right it's kind
of prancing about right so I like that a
lot
mm-hmm the chest is puffed out mm-hmm
the head is up it feels very proud yeah
I know I know that they're definitely a
proud to us right um right right so
these are these are all things these are
qualities that you know we could bacon
the story or see the story kind of shine
through of the heritage of the house and
where they come from what they stand for
mm-hmm one little comment I would make
here is the antlers the the horizontal
shape is nice and graphic I think I
would have just reduced that down a
little bit to give a little more weight
to the rest of the antlers because it
looks like eyelashes right now so the
proportion between the horizontal
crossbar and antlers spiking up I think
could be a little bit more like the way
they look on the ends the proportion so
the ends look really strong but the ones
in between Matthew you know what I'm
talking about so the left and right
parts of the antler look really strong
and thick proportionate to the
horizontal stroke right but inside the
interior antler parts look a little bit
thin and dainty so that's the one thing
that I would suggest that you look at
okay but really good job the other thing
I would say is maybe the the negative
shape of the ear could be a little bit
smaller so it's just a nice thick shape
for the ear we don't want to get lost in
detail at all mm-hmm okay
and some people are commenting tooth
like they they like guess they're they
have their own suggestions like one
person suggests I don't really like the
eye you know that's debatable because
the eye is the window to the soul the
doorway into the soul so when you look
at that if you wanted it to look more
aggressive we can definitely use more
geometric shapes in there
this person show chose to use a round
circle there so it definitely has a
little bit more of a friendly feeling to
it it's a little bit softer so maybe
that was the intent I'm not sure right
but those are the subtle things that you
can do with just one tiny element like
that the eye the
shape definitely can convey the tone of
what the the position of the animal or
subject is he's trying to portray their
yeah I don't have a problem with the I
whatsoever just keeping it super graphic
geometric there's a lot of design
decisions that are made here that I
think show me that this is what a
well-crafted thing so good job taejun
taejun Kim and I think it's TJ K
underscore design good job now the
reason why I say this is because
oftentimes people say that's not a logo
that's not a mark and I just can't
really tell you all the time that I know
what a logo remark looks like but
usually when it looks like an
illustration where it's too true to life
then I feel like it's going into
illustration land it's not like a hard
formula that can tell you X percentage
of this but simplifying things
interpreting through the artists or the
designers eye is really to me what makes
it a graphic mark a symbol and not just
an illustration okay realize I'm
off-center here and with them move
myself over okay
let's move on next up kind of my eye
side is just going here but this one so
this one issues the entire head and the
body for the antlers and the crown
itself there's some really interesting
things going on here first its utilizing
a lot of the shape and contours to the
shape itself again good choice there it
feels like they're flames so it's
between antlers and flames like a hot
rod I think that's pretty cool it's got
a crown in there and I like that a lot
my one critique of this one is that the
crown feels a little like clipart he
doesn't feel as custom and doesn't
seemingly keeping the same visual
language as the antlers now you notice
the antlers they don't come to a sharp
point they have a little curved circular
thing so it has a certain vibe to it yet
when I look at the the crown itself it's
super sharp and it's very precise and I
think this is where you want to kind of
keep the tonality in a similar universe
and it's throwing me off just a little
bit your thought Matthew yeah I agree I
feel like the qualities of the crown and
the antlers are a little too different
I'd rather them be more contrasty in
terms of how different they are or make
them very very similar so I feel like
those two things feel like they're
coming from different worlds a little
bit mm-hmm I do like the use of the
horns in this crest shape so I
definitely think that part is the
strength of this and there's something
interesting to be said that the that you
see the antlers holding up the crown
there's something about that and I think
about their history and their background
and I think about their support for the
throne support for the crown and them
also trying to claim that they are the
the true rightful Kings throughout the
series so it's it's an interesting it's
an interesting mark yeah we better be
careful about how we describe these
things the hardcore Game of Thrones fans
like you guys don't know what you're
talking that's right the kings of the
kingdom okay let's look at the next one
[Music]
this is from Caitlyn Tyndall and first
of all I want to tell you guys that
we're able to download the template and
using the template and keeping
everything super simple allows it to fit
within our grid and makes it super clean
a lot of you guys are getting really
creative with changing colors and
changing all the information at the
bottom just creating heartache for us
living images in the background yeah we
don't need any of that stuff but you
know on the sea residual that's all be
confident in your sigil and don't worry
about anything else so this one's from
Caitlyn Trindle and I don't know Matthew
but I think thus far all the submissions
have been women hmm the names are all
women and I love this this is fantastic
so great way to represent women awesome
job designers so here we go again
here's the understad this one's like
kind of kicking up a little bit more
aggressive stance and it's also turning
its head there are some interesting
decisions being made with antlers a
they're not symmetrical which throws me
off a little bit
mm-hm a little bit and they look a
little bit like thorns on this one
mm-hmm which would have been great for
Tyrell right right great for Tyrell I
also like that there's some kind of
lighting effect being applied here so
that there seems to be some
dimensionality but the lighting effect
is very flat I would have preferred
actually if you got in here and picked a
lighting source and did a little bit
more with contouring so that we see the
edges kind of lit as if they're
dimensional not just front lighting and
making everything look flat right so
you're just saying right right I see so
the way that the lighting is applied the
shadows are
getting thicker around the edges of the
contours yes of the silhouette and it
feels like we have a front light the way
that this yes but you're looking for
like a side light or three-quarter light
a three-quarter light would be very
dramatic maybe up or right pointing down
towards it I think that would look
really really really good in terms of
the antlers I personally like the
antlers here just because I don't mind
the asymmetrical nests because of how it
fills the top left of the the sigil here
I like how the use of space is being
used overall this is very dynamic so
what's different about this versus some
of the other ones we just saw this is
going from bottom left to top right and
it has this dynamic feel where almost
feels like this bag is trying to break
out of this sigil shape so there's
something that's very inherently dynamic
there's a lot of motion that I
personally really like I like how all
the elements kind of fill this space and
take advantage of that and again with
the antlers I know it feels like thorns
but it does have that a little bit of
aggression to it right and they're there
how saying is ours is the fury right I
believe I don't know Gordon according to
the wiki that yeah yeah of course
sorry right that's what it says Matthew
that's exactly okay a couple of things I
want to point out to this one I am aside
from the lighting and my my issues with
the antlers I'm curious try this take
the right side of the stag and the
antlers and just mirror it to the left
and see if it impacts your design
negatively or not because I think in a
lot of these sigils balance is really
important it wants to be strong right it
wants to feel like it's not gonna tip
over on itself the next little thing I
want to point out is these little lines
that you've added that follow the
contour of the shield the shape that the
crest itself I don't think you need it I
think that's a lot of detail that you
don't need I'll give you another thought
here is if you were to make that the
highlight actually a black shape and put
it behind the stag I think that would
look pretty dope cuz then from afar you
gonna see this really like nice yellow
and black contrasting shape and as you
get closer you'll know that the stag is
breaking free from it so if you connect
the top parts of the highlights so the
the top part of it is yellow and then
the bottom part is inverted in black and
you put the stag in there I think
look really cool that's another way to
do it you guys you've heard me say this
many many times before focused on shape
and not lines symbols logos focus on
shapes not lines that's what we're
looking for
mm-hmm okay good job Kaitlyn very good
let's move on okay this is now from
Amanda Liu Amanda Luce super graphic Wow
this one's really nice Matthew what are
you what's your take on this
I love how bold this is I like that it's
flat I like the actual the little hint
of white on the face there we were just
talking about lighting earlier and
there's ways to imply that I think this
is an interesting way to give the
front-facing view of this deer oh sorry
stag a little bit of dimension so I like
that a lot I like how the horns are
treated here it's very graphic we don't
have all the secondary antlers breaking
out but you just have all of this kind
of straight up so it feels very firm it
feels very strong in terms of its stance
you know it feels like a very proud
animal here so there's there's a lot
going on in here I just love how how
simple it is and how boiled down that is
this is if seeing it from far away if I
squint my eyes
it's very legible nice contrast nice
shape and past the squint test passed
the squint test yes I like how geometric
the antlers are here very nice design
very balanced symmetrical really strong
my one critique here mm-hmm
as we're looking to pick the five
finalists here I was just like if we
took away the antlers what animal is
this and no it's really hard to read a
deers face from the front Pro from
straight on so that's what the one thing
is like what can we do to make this look
a little bit more like hmm a deer and it
could look like a long nosed cow there's
a couple things in there that just throw
me off a little bit but really Amanda
beautiful job great great job that tells
me something we have a very educated and
talented audience that's watching this
show because I'm just overall an
impression in terms of what was
submitted you never know what these
kinds of competition you never know
who's gonna show up what kind of energy
and effort they're gonna put in but
right I really like this and there's one
other little detail want to point out
that was really nice
look at the way the bottom of the deer
is finished off of the stats this is
kind of jagged edge so it's kind of
suggest like the coat of fur
you know something mean on this thing I
don't know how I don't know anything
about deer but it looks really regal and
just like I'm ready to go yeah there's
something really nice so this is like
details matter what do you think about
the little white I put did you already
talk about that yeah Matthew talked
about the light lighting on half the
gears face yes yeah I mean I think
that's the only way that you might give
this dimension so that it's legible as a
shape in terms of what the head shape is
going to look like but I think what
Chris was talking about earlier another
way to solve this potentially is by
having the deer turn profile if you have
the turn profile then you can clearly
see the shape of the face I don't know
if that would destroy it but in the
earlier slide the other exploration that
we saw there was definitely a version of
that word is angled and it is flat so
there's a way to solve it if you play
around with that like that is an
interesting one and if you go to the to
the other one where it was looks like
it's trotting like this one obviously is
still very dimensional it and just like
a lot of Egyptian hieroglyphs and a lot
of old illustration they do these funny
things where they take something that's
at an angle and they flatten it out so I
think there's ways to solve this that
might be applicable to this graphic
version that we're looking at
potentially sometimes when we get into
reducing something that being very
reductive in our design process we have
to be very careful because now you only
have a few lines to describe the image
and you need to just pick the right line
so looking back this thing have one
other little comment that I'm noticing
right now when white goes to yellow
there's very low contrast between those
two so if you look at the highlight on
half the Stags head and there's a
connection to the nose the difference
between the white yellow are so minor I
just think you got to go with white nose
and I got I got a suggestion here for
you Amanda if I may is if you take the
bottom of the nose and you connect it to
that white shape and just made all white
okay that's one way another way is just
to highlight an edge of the nose so that
it starts to disappear as you go to the
right I think that would also add a
little dimensionality to this thing to
create it the illusion that it's
protruding forward and it's not
completely flat right so just some
little tweaks there
do you I was thinking too we might be
able to notch out see if you see on my
face there's a shadow right here on my
chin that could be like a graphic slice
that we take out on the the front view
of this stag that might give the head a
little bit more shape that could be
interesting yes that too yep
okay all right let's move on to House
Targaryen fire and blood fire and blood
who the the House Targaryen probably had
the most submissions because a it's got
dragons and Daenerys Targaryen the
mother of dragons breaker of chains you
know what else we know all of the things
all of the things yes first of her name
you know whatever Denarius is Khaleesi
Khaleesi I mean she's she's a heroine in
this story and and just dragons are
super cool so let's take a look at the
submissions here here's one from James
is it bets can't read that looks like it
yeah yeah sorry guys it's James bets at
bets underscore design so this one's
really nice this is got a dragon and
it's kind of completed in a circle and
it's also got this nice little detail
the spine I have some thoughts on this
this is one of the ones we're gonna dive
in a little deeper and I'm gonna see if
I can't just make a few critical tweaks
to it to see if I can't sharpen it up a
little bit yeah I know when you want to
use the word make it better I just want
to sharpen it up a little bit there's a
couple things that bothered me up front
one is where are the wings like in the
tail it's all kind of blending together
a little bit to create this shape mm-hmm
and I think you would easily get rid of
the tail part that's completing the
upper part of the circle you just remove
that and show the wings a little bit
more I think that'll look really cool I
think you could just imply that circle
there right yeah yeah not that your I
finished the circle correct you don't
need it and then there's this little
white shape that looks like it's
stabbing it in the belly what is that I
wonder if it's the end of the tail like
it's kind of coming around and that's
the end of the tail because the tail
sometimes has little point you know what
it is it's a negative shape at the
bottom of the wing hmm you see like
though there's a little thing on the
wing there Matthew and then there's just
a big gap between the bottom of the
and the belly it's creating a really
awkward shape there so I think it's what
Matthew said no into the tail well the
thing is like because we're having the
debate it's not clear yeah it's already
a little odd right okay and the other
thing that I think just for my own
preference here is to use lines that
have thick and thins not to use just
strokes that are linear or mono stroke
because it makes the thing look really
flat
those are just my comments and I'm gonna
try my best to jump in here and do
something about it but we'll see what
happens okay no promises okay next one
this one is super cool this is from Erin
gross Erin gross sue is so graphic yeah
Ricky were you gonna say something no
okay
so Erin gross submitted this one I think
Erin submitted quite a few and this
one's really lovely it in his in his
abstraction in his abstraction I think
we're losing a little bit of the
dragon's head right I think that's the
only thing I think gosh if they could
have if he could have worked that out
that would have been pretty cool but you
know the interesting thing is even
without reading the description of this
already knew which house it was for
mm-hm
so I think he was definitely right on
the line between is it legible and can
you understand where that which house
this represents yes I think because it
has the three heads on there you know
that it represents the three dragons
yeah it's still pretty good but you're
right there little details matter it's
really good guys
come on I'm not gonna even pretend like
I can draw this if I it's also clever
too if you see at first I was wondering
why is there a little why is the tail
broken on the bottom left but it's
really just the tail curling yes there's
a loop yeah I like that so that that
that threw me for a little loop there
okay I think the reason why there's a
little loop there is because probably
I'm imagining this when he was designing
this there was a little negative space
there that he wanted to fill so he
wanted to put something in there so the
loop made sense that could have easily
also been solved by extending the foot
out a little bit so that we don't have a
loop but you like the loop it's all good
it's there awesome Ricky did you want to
say something look has the audience
grown any
at all to twenty one to twenty one to
twenty two as far as I know right yeah
good a lot of critiques there's not so
many questions as far is there any on
their own critiques yeah I don't suspect
too many questions since you guys are
just bringing in your own points of view
which I love fantastic yeah okay here's
another one this one's from Kenta
Yoshida and Kento I believe also
submitted several things and this is
really beautiful drawing of dragons it's
a really nice drawing so Kento I don't
know if you drew this but if you did
you're you're really good illustrator I
could see that you know how to draw okay
now having said that I like the idea
also of this infinity where each dragon
kind of melds into itself right and
there's three of them these kinds of
designs are pretty hard to do mm-hmm
unless you're a Japanese school child
because that's apparently what all
Japanese children know how to do is to
draw symbols that repeat like this right
I'll watch the video and that was like
amazing no wonder they're so good yeah
there's some legibility issues here and
there's a little bit too much detail in
it for me personally and I think it
would have been much stronger if you did
it where the dragon was eating its own
tail so it wasn't just literally the
same dragon over lapping itself right
and yeah one other thing I think on all
of his submissions he threw over this
scratchy texture yeah even though I like
the grungy stuff like it's it's very
hard to judge these things because now
you're adding another layer of something
distraction where it almost feels like
you're hiding the the details of the
original sigil so I understand why you
did it but you know it's for me as
somebody trying to review this is a
little distracting I don't think you
need it I don't think you need to know
it's really good mark be confident in
your design skills and I think Kento is
probably just being trying to plus it
like ah go the extra mile and sometimes
we have to know when enough is enough
right and don't don't lose ourselves in
the process of displaying it right okay
so oddly enough here's another
submission from Kento - so Ken tell
loves dragons this looks you know this
looks like what cuz you're right
I mean if you take away the horns no
what what you say no no you guys think
it's a yellow flag but that's how it's
pronounced in Japan see gaudy does go
surah the ELSA pronounces ours and ours
who pronounces ELLs that is strange
yes it's not like ID dot there you go
again Ricky it's totally different
there's an analogy no now you've learned
nothing from last night's two-hour
conversation anyway I like this
illustration a lot it's a really good
representation of a dragon I would wear
this on a t-shirt it's I would wait
t-shirt in a heartbeat you've added some
texture to this and I think the texture
in this case isn't distracting to me at
all it's really nice drawing man Kenta
let's talk after this maybe you can
illustrate some things for us no
monsters this is a guy guide you know
guy what are they what do they call
monsters in the big the big monster
guide you yeah yeah yeah this is this is
cool is it symmetrical
it looks symmetrical to me right yeah
I'm just I'm just wondering I couldn't
tell maybe just a little bits of texture
that help rebalance it cuz normally I
don't like stuff that's too symmetrical
but this is a this is interesting I do
love symmetry you know what I just
noticed right now to the nostril and the
dragon feels very much like an ape a
simian and there's a human quality to it
that's also another thing that Japanese
are really good at actually an Eastern
culture the dragons are not seen as this
menacing thing is it is in Western
culture so they have much more
humanistic qualities like eyebrows
beards they're seen as wise protectors
versus just creatures destroy everything
that's just a difference in how cultures
perceive certain symbols and imaginary
creatures this does this pass the squint
test for you no it doesn't and I wanted
to bring that up because even though the
illustration is quite beautiful and
ornate if you squint at it the face is
completely gone because the black flag
and the dark red of this that he chose
it's just they're too close mmm so
there's a contrast issue here that it's
it's distracting so what have you made
the face white would that be okay for
you I mean that would be interesting I
think
this is a value issue so we'd probably
have to tweakin and see what might work
but definitely needed a little bit more
contrast in the value so that all this
nice work doesn't get hidden because
from far away I wouldn't be able to tell
what this is yeah okay so this is his
Instagram is at key KY logo for Kento
Yoshida i'm really curious in a little
bit i'm gonna jump in and just look him
up just because i want to see the rest
of his work i'm looking for an
illustrator who knows how to draw like
this so let's see what happens yeah okay
let's move on then the last submission
for House Targaryen is this one from
Ashraf
I'm not even try to say the last name
its Ashraf right and this is a super
graphic reduction and we saw one before
where the head didn't quite look like a
dragon I think this one looks more like
a dragon and the wings are so abstract
it's really really cool mm-hmm my
comment for you here is this is I wonder
if this would look better if the border
was thinner and the mark was bigger yeah
I feel like the hierarchy is flipped on
this where the boldness comes from the
border I know why you did it
mm-hmm but I think we want to focus more
on the symbol itself right and it also
makes the Dragons feel weak it makes
them feel small and it makes them a
dragon yeah they're the baby dragons
right but I think it would be better if
it broke it like if you use a border
like this it might even be interesting
if the wings break the edges of the
border so it feels like it's coming out
so you could do these little dimensional
things where it gives it a little bit
more energy and a little bit more kind
of like a dynamic look where you're
playing with these flat elements to make
it feel like it's it's coming forward or
coming out so there's like little things
like that that I could imagine but I
agree with you in terms of the the
hierarchy it definitely needs to be
flipped here but yeah I love the
reduction it's it's very interesting to
read it right away because I know what
it is even though only a few lines yeah
another way to do this is to scale up
the Dragons and to the point in which
the borders end right there and then
take these this in line this border and
cut it cut it so it's just the bottom
half as if you dip the sigil in red
paint mm-hmm and then you just create a
shape and then the Dragons can stand
proud of that so you can introduce the
second color there and I think that'd be
nice that way
from afar you can recognize the shape
right away all right let's move on to
house and Greyjoy we do not so we do not
so they're the Pirates of the show okay
first up and Ricky and Rick a who's
who's trying to call me during the last
chamber sorry Matthew
okay it's probably something else okay
so this one is really really interesting
to me okay so this is an R ek and the
reason why it's interesting to me I mean
it's it's not it's a squid there's an
octopus no this is a squid it's a Kraken
it's at cracking its cracking it's a
giant squid right and they're the
terrors of the Seas you can't mess
around with them because they don't so
they just steal things from people
they're pirates essentially and I look
at this I'm like this is really cool
mark it reads it's not an easy symbol to
draw and there's a second image in here
that I see a skull in air which is
really well done that's cool there are
the tears of the sea look at that you
guys it's pretty dope and in this case I
think the border is not overpowering
because there's enough weight and mass
within the bottom part the head of the
of the Kraken then it works just good
color choice good rent rendering what do
you think Matthew yeah I think it's very
clever I definitely like that I you know
one thing I would like to say I don't
enjoy symmetry as much as you do so I
would love to see a variant of this
words just slightly asymmetrical where
the tentacles on each side are just
slightly offset like one extends further
than the other because I think you could
still accomplish the same second read of
the skull wood and give it a little bit
more interest if it wasn't perfectly
symmetrical but that's just me that's
just my preference hmm okay last one
from this group is from Christopher pium
pium Christopher km and this one's a
really really beautiful mark - thank you
this is another Kraken but it's done in
very geometric way so it looks like a
beautiful pattern of circles until you
step back wait a minute the pirates
they're gonna kill us that's who they
are so it's kind of deceptive from afar
looks like a flower and as soon as you
start to figure it out there's a great
squid in there
it's awesome good job on this one yeah I
like it because the tentacles feel very
active like they're moving and they feel
a little treacherous it feels like these
are the
and tentacles you know could just reach
out and whip you in the face pretty soon
so there's there's a lot of interesting
movement even though this one is
symmetrical this one is contained it
feels like it's about to unfurl and
break out so I really like that part of
this this design it feels like a new
killer symbol to me because the black
and yellow and it kind of like has that
same kind of shape for me oh yeah I know
we're talking about is it that biohazard
boy mm-hmm yeah let's kind of feel like
that mm-hmm
okay let's move on house Aaron as high
as honor up in the Eyrie of the Vale
there's a moon a crescent moon and a
falcon I believe that's when the house
symbol is and there were quite a few
submissions on this so we can tell which
houses are popular maybe maybe you guys
like birds and Dragons but okay here we
go
so this has the crescent moon at the top
it's creating a really nice shape so
here this is done by still Sylvane
Sylvane rutty rathi
okay Sylvain good job trying to complete
the circle there with the wing implying
that there's those things are connected
also very difficult to do it's an
interesting rendering of a falcon from
atop I think there's some decisions made
here that kind of make it look a little
less bird-like for me but it's a really
beautiful mark my favorite part actually
is the colors at this one mm-hmm
there's there's an elegance to it this
muted purple and this muted gold yeah it
feels like those are very regal colors
those are very royal colors and there's
something that's just really nice about
the subtlety and how this is approached
so a combination of the simplicity of
this as well as those muted colors
really stood out for me mm-hmm so I
guess they want you over the colors on
this one right but I I think first for
the shapes I agree with you
I think there's just some issues that I
have with the rendering and how the
shapes could be completed here mm-hmm
because the bird doesn't quite read and
the crescent moon I think could use a
little bit of work yeah it also doesn't
quite read to right it needs to taper
faster towards the end mm-hmm I think
yeah tell me about your thinking about
thoughts it looks like there's a double
image here right so set your camera oh
you want to cut to me yeah when you're
talking
about the mark those and it okay it's
fine yeah yeah go ahead so it's it's
like if you step back it's like a bird's
face looking right at you yeah I guess
so the wings are the eyes I think he's
saying yeah but right that's like an
owl's eye or something that's right it
doesn't look like a hawk right is that
what Falcon Falcon sorry yeah so even if
that was the intent yet which could be
clever yeah yeah you know it doesn't
necessarily read as a I know what you
mean Aaron because otherwise then it
looks like a really strange looking set
of eyes with a weird nose looking at you
right that's what I think is like the
main the main thing he was going for
right mm-hmm I don't think so well
actually you know what actually it is so
sylveon you read it thank you so this
right I'm reading yeah okay place the
beige with the golden yellow yeah this
one soars against the moon if you look
closely if you look further the Falcons
head it's something the Falcons head he
ran out of characters to type no that's
not definitive
that's not definitive at all but I'll
give Aaron the benefit of the doubt yeah
I know designers like to do these like
double triple images you know there's
already two images in here right the
crescent moon and the span of the wings
with the Falcon from the top view right
a lot of times you guys try to get too
clever you try to make everything look
at everything else and just becomes a
little bit of a compromise mm-hm and I
think that's where it's throwing me off
a little bit right obviously made the
top fifty so there's some really good
things about this and I too was drawn
into this kind of muted purple and
bronzy gold color I like that mm-hmm
so for sure so Aaron sees the unseen
good job Aaron beautiful job okay next
up is Adrian sigh or see Adrian si si si
si si alright I like this one okay I
though you told me to say okay there we
go all right here we go super geometric
the bird has been reduced down to just
almost its bare minimum which is the
span of the wings and a little point for
the tail I think looks really good and
then there's this little drop so I look
at it like they remove the negative
space in the wing on the top scaled it
down and dropped at the bottom it's
a nice anchoring point and it just
suggests the moon or relationship
between the moon and Earth
so that's could move and could be the
thing at the bottom and earth is thing
at the top I think that's really cool
yeah I was reading the description
that's actually the rest of the world
the drop at the bottom yeah and then
they are the moon okay right yeah but I
love I see they're like watching the
world right I love the definitely the
reduction the simplification because you
could still read the wings you can read
the moon and I don't know this is so
bold so of our you know metrics that
we're judging this stuff by I think
uniqueness and boldness are the ones
that definitely stand out for this
particular mark yeah you see the little
cuts in the wing those are not easy to
do why not because it implies that
there's a little bit more dimensionality
because you've seen other ones where
they just draw a flat line Ricky yeah
and then it makes the whole thing look
really flat where you can see that where
the gaps are where it moves away from
the point and it opens up a little bit
it feels like the edge of the wing is
tipping towards you like it's furling
inside so it's dimensional and I could
totally see this as a three-dimensional
sculpture where we look at it in front
of the front it looks like this but when
you look on inside it's actually it's
got a concave to it
gotcha right look it's bending towards
you like a skateboard has a curvature to
it okay right should I make an analogy
yeah try to make it visual for you Ricky
I guess you jo-jo Carmen Carmen note
Carmen Ola says as high as honor as high
as honor right that's third that's our
model so I think that it hits that motto
yeah this captures that okay let's move
on
this one's from Guillen or Gian cruise
or guy on cruise a probably jian jian
jian cruise okay here we go
and this is another super highly
abstracted mark and it's got the wings
it's got the crescent moon and there's
no bird but you get all that you need
from this one graphic and I love it and
there's two shades of the white there's
white and then there's kind of a lighter
purple or something like that
and it just shows again a little
dimensionality and it's super super
simple yeah I get I could see this a it
passes the squint test you know easily
this from far away I love the reduction
again very simple I shall like the
curved edge if you look at the top of
where the wings and there's a little bit
of a curb edge to the top there so that
makes it feel more feather like so I
think that was a nice little detail
otherwise if that wasn't there I don't
know if it would read as wings as well
mm-hmm mm-hmm okay moving on this is
from John's this is not John Smith Smith
that's just they didn't change out the
name at the bottom jab jab and I can't
even pronounce the names JAV oh you G
and E
did they jeongu Jovan Jovan Jovan maybe
I don't know or maybe African is there
is there a handle on the bottom or no
this one literally says John Smith at
John smell okay so they didn't change
any of that
well whatever we're not gonna focus on
John Smith's work here obviously this is
not John Smith's work this one has the
Falcon flying towards the what is it I
forget what it's called the Veil the
veil it's called a veil they preside in
the veil and the castle is called the
Eyrie and thanks for calling it the
mountain Aaron cuz I didn't know that
word
this one's a little strange for me
because the crescent moon is at the
bottom right which looks a little odd
because it's creating and trapping a
little negative space at the bottom it
also looks like an odd smile there's
something funky as heck about it so here
are my suggestions for you you could
have easily placed the crescent moon at
the top of the mountain range and then
take take your Falcon which is
beautifully drawn by the way and scale
it up so it breaks the circle mm-hmm so
it's flying over the circle implies some
dimension there - yeah I don't know if
you need that little border again
you guys are adding things to it I just
don't know if you need it I mean I like
the the contrast and the weight of
elements right the middle is very heavy
and then you have this light petite
thing on the outside yeah so I like the
relationship of the two but again I
don't know that it's necessarily needed
yeah okay
let's move on from John Smith's work
this is another one from Kanto Yoshida
well this is one prolific Wow okay
Kendall's like the men are not
representing I'll just do all the work I
just do a mall okay so Kento has proven
to me once again he I think where she
knows how
draw really well and this is a really
beautifully drawn Falcon with the claws
out on the end the tail and the way it's
rendered and the crescent moon on top
when I think of sigils and in the
classic sense like jerseys also for like
Barcelona of soccer team or football
team I kind of see this and it's really
nicely drawn and I just have an
appreciation for your illustration
skills and the shape that this creates
unlike with the dragon for House
Targaryen this one really feels like you
could see it from afar and you can also
appreciate it from the details up close
right thoughts Matthew yeah
no I love the integration of the curve
of the crescent moon on the top and how
it leads into the wings of the bird
mm-hmm the bird does feel very prominent
and proud there's there's a nice posture
to it a nice dance within the shape of
the swings out plaza yeah like there's
there's something very there's there's
in it you know Eevee yeah with the claws
out it's kind of expanding out so it
feels like it's about to break from this
containing shape so I really like that
quite a bit this also says don't mess
with me I'll Peck your eyes out and I'll
claw off your face right it's not a very
when we know in the animal kingdom when
the animal takes up a lot of space it's
showing you don't mess with me right
right when it rears up on its legs
that's what it's saying back off because
I'll kill you and even like the the tail
detail at the bottom that way that the
love that I've come here looks like a
saint like a fleur-de-lis yeah exactly
mm-hmm okay let's move on this one is
from Lauren creates at Lauren creates I
didn't get the name because Lauren did
not follow the template on this one I
didn't wanna just make this up at the
bottom so Lauren was able to make this
one this one also got into the top 50
it's got the Falcon head it's got an eye
like we're watching you from the top of
the Eyrie and I don't know if there's a
moon in there but just I think the eye
is the moon
that's the crescent moon oh okay so it's
an eye moon yeah it's it's kind of weird
I think it's too many things kind of
right away like that I love the best
thing about this is the use of the shape
this is one of the better ones where
it's really taking this container and
making it super dynamic so we have this
nice little swirl where its leading you
right into the center of this sigil
mm-hmm leading you right into the
crescent moon so I really love how this
person use the space yep but I feel like
it is too many reads like I just want to
read two things at most probably yes
and I want to point out one other detail
here is that I think Lauren knows how to
do logo grading really well because if
you look at the way the beak terminates
and comes down towards the bottom part
of the hi that's a circle right there
and look at the eye of the the Falcon
it's also a circle and you can see that
she or he is probably doing a really
good job of understanding
I got a sketch and I'm gonna try and
make it fit towards these geometric
shapes to achieve that kind of timeless
bold quality mm-hmm okay and this is
also one of the ones where I'm gonna
dive a little deeper in and I'm gonna
just draw a little bit on top of it to
see what else we can do
there's some funny shapes in there too I
have to say mm-hmm but you know the
throat of the bird the Falcon right see
how the it's thickly right there and
then it tapers out there's some funky
stuff going on right you see that
Matthew yep yep but I think for both of
us this would you say this caught our
eye it definitely okay moving on so
let's move on to house Tyrell growing
strong not a ton of submissions from
house Tyrell a very difficult one to
work with because you're dealing with
the rose and thorns I think that's what
they got there in Highgarden and it's
pretty much what you know about house
Tyrell they basically grow all the food
for the kingdom mm-hmm is it the Seven
Kingdoms yeah and you know they're
wealthy also they're very wealthy
because they grow all the food that's
right okay so here's the first one from
Tom whiting if I'm reading it right Tom
whiting so simple shape here
I hate Tom we don't really need a little
black outline on the crest itself just
just get rid of that just I don't I
don't know what that's for maybe you
forgot hirato I don't know
anyways I like this very geometric again
I believe just based on my own
experience is very hard to draw these
symbols that interlock and repeat kind
of is in His perfect infinite loop so
have great admiration for you ability to
do that
and then you have this outer ring a
circle kind of TISS the nest the rows in
and then these little abstracted
versions of thorns you could look a
little like barbed wire which I like I'm
gonna say something right now that's
going to also be reflected in the second
one a rose is not exactly like a strong
house but that reflects their house
right that's not but I thought what's
that that's it's like hard to make
something that a sigil seems like you're
going to battle yeah yeah they're
they're not fighters and in in the
storyline they know they're not fighters
farmers they grow food right but I think
you could have taken somehow this
element from the outer two circles that
you have and may maybe make them
intertwine somehow and make it look like
- roses criss-crossing around with
thorns hmm I think that would have been
a really strong way to handle this just
to really get that kind of barbed wire
rose like don't mess with us either if
you if you handle this incorrectly will
prick your fingers you know you'll bleed
mm-hmm yeah okay let's move on this is
now can't read this
well somebody broke the template here
and wanted to change the background
color I design right night design the
stays silent that's not good night I
don't say yeah all right I don't know I
don't know I says but anyways another
another strong submission here for for
this house and what do we got here we
got another rose in the center and then
we have a five spoke wheel and at first
I looked at this I'm like wait a minute
it's just for the I'm forgetting all the
houses right now the Tyrell no not
Tyrell the the ones Greyjoy house
Greyjoy because there's this what looks
to be like the steering wheel of a ship
I saw in the last one - yeah yeah
there's a little bit of that kind of
nautical vibe that's why I wanted to
make sure we steer away from that and it
could be a little bit more organic right
but the inner Rose is really beautifully
drawn it almost looks like the blue like
on you know I'm talking about Matthew
mm-hmm yeah but it's really nice again
these things are not easy to draw a lot
of respect for you yeah I think the
thing that drew me and on this one was
just that drawing of the Rose I loved
the the kind of repeating pattern and
that swirl that's bringing you right
into
center of this piece I like that it
feels a little bit tight you know it's
kind of bringing you in there but I
agree with you the outer shape I don't
think necessarily helps that and it
doesn't help clarify the the
illustration or the the sigil anymore
yep okay let's move on do are there any
questions you guys want us to keep doing
this do you want me to get go a little
faster a little slower
how we doing our work we're out of 50
right 22 out of 50 right now it looks
like no we're not showing all of them
okay it's a little bit too much and
we're going to show you the ones that we
pick from the 50 color wise just be a
three-day that's live stream Isis so I
think if it's not 50 then I think we're
okay some people I mean where we were at
2:46 classic hey Ricky do you speak into
the microphone we're at 254 right now
Chris so people are still interested
great scrolling everybody's just having
their comments on each on each mark so
okay fantastic keep going keep going
yep all right next up is House Lannister
their motto is hear me roar hear me roar
okay House Lannister boom
hope there's a little line in there okay
this is the this is from Jack from Jack
my eyes are going here Jack and Joe let
let yeah Jack Paulette thank you
eagle-eye yeah you get full screen I get
half screen yeah okay this is a
front-facing line with the main and
there's something really interesting in
terms of this sharp serrated shape
that's reflected kind of like the shape
of the sigil mm-hmm how many s-sounds
gonna say sharp serrated shape of the
sigil by the seashore by the seashore
yes okay and I think that there's
something really cool about that the
lion's face reads really well and
there's this edge to the line and also
there's a crown on the line III what I
like is I actually like the top part of
the lion yes much better than the bottom
part of the lion you know I like the
shape it's just there's some really cool
design element going on there yeah I was
gonna say the top part is nice because
you see that subtle crown there at the
top right the way then it's also getting
supported by the lion's mane at the top
almost feels like this regal haircut
right like nice flowing hair and then at
the bottom it's just the the bottom part
the lion's mane just feel like it's too
chunky and it's competing with the face
so if we were to rebalance this I would
say that it would be nicer if the face
was a little bit bigger and more
prominent and then we reduced the
thickness or the prominence of the
bottom part of the Lions Mane's this is
so that we get a little bit more of a
better read on this yeah so a couple
things we should definitely just take
what you've drawn and scale it up to
feel more of a frame because that's what
we're focused on and then what I would
suggest is the the way that you handled
the top part of the lion's mane you
continue throughout and see what happens
because I think that detail will allow
the head of the line to pop out more
mm-hmm okay good job there jack palate
okay next one up is from Steven Manuel
Steven Manuel or Manuel okay and this is
really interesting it's got a kind of
reductive almost kind of a scratchboard
vibe right we're like Frank what is that
German I'm just forgetting woodblock you
guys what I'm talking about I don't know
who studied art history come on you guys
have my history I have German Abstract
Expressionism whatever I'm just gonna
throw it out there somebody holding me
for it I'm sure of it but it's it's a
really nice mark and and I just like
that it's just using negative shape and
this was wrong sense of lighting we get
we get the sense that it's lit from the
top of the lion's head right and all I
was thinking was I know that it fits
within the main where proportionately
but I just feel like it's a little too
far south I'm gonna nudge it up
everybody's agreeing yes yeah it feels
like The Lion King to me okay
no yeah yeah well blank ink well if you
want to see Lion King I'll show you
lying right now um from the Broadway
play yeah yeah remember according segi
Aviv we're not allowed to say it looks
like or reminds me of right okay yes one
of his opening clayey because of course
it's gonna look like something and I
probably have already said it myself too
but okay so just try to refrain from
this I have not okay
I am a few you wound me sir I bleed you
know what why did we give Matthew the
sound Maddie how the soundboard one time
that's my job today
and he goes bananas on it he's giving
himself all the kudos you give him she
never give Matthew control okay next up
oh wow this is great this is from
Mustafa been on run like how perfect is
that name for this Mustafa
that's pretty different Lion King his
name was Tom Mufasa Mufasa really close
yeah that's a good memory there Ricardo
it's a great movie this one's very
different compared to all the previous
ones that we saw they really utilize all
the space inside the the crest shape
that you provided it's very abstract yet
I think you could still see that it
looks like a mean line right at the then
you can see it yeah it's very abstract
and it's really beautiful I can see this
as a tapestry or a chess plate or a
piece on somebody's armor and I can see
that I love the lines the lines all
coming converging towards the center of
the face the perspective lines are
really really nice in this okay
there somebody might argue it's like
could it look a little bit more like a
lion maybe yes or the hair maybe a just
one of those lines a little bit and the
line will pop out but really well done
Mustafa and also excellent name
excellent choice all around good job
last but not least another one from
Kensal Yoshida oh my gosh I'm telling
you guys he is tearing it apart he's
doing the work of 30 designers right now
or she I don't even know kento's Kento
I think Enzo's a guy named but you could
let us know so if you're on the stream
right yes apologies in advance
anyways Kento is doing the work of 30
designers fantastic okay like I said
Kento knows how to draw so here's
another rendering of a lion and its main
looks a lot like flames and I think
that's pretty cool right
so like this is a lion with hair gel
really strong product there so I see
that and I think that's really cool the
one thing that's bothering me about this
drawing Kento is the
I'm part of the Lions jaw it's it looks
like if you look at it you flip this
thing upside down it looks like a skull
with his mouth open sharp teeth you guys
see that
like Day of the Dead skull yeah now then
I say you cannot unsee it's one of those
things right yeah it's like the
beautiful maiden and then the bold
richard wenches yeah yes and maybe that
was the intent there there's there's two
sides to this right who knows now I
would say that something is funny about
the ear the jaw the bottom of the mouth
it's somewhere between baboon dragon
lion I think we just need to work on
that a little bit so it's really clear
what it is I can't put my finger on it
but a baboon kind of has a similar face
it could also be easily if you added a
long neck to this it could easily
transform into a dragon so we just got
to work on that and then you have this
breath or flame vapor coming from it and
I think I know why you did that because
you want to fill up some of the negative
shape and because you know Matthew
doesn't like symmetry you threw that in
there it's also echoing the same shapes
in the lion's mane itself so there's
those kinds of what is that called flame
wicks of fire or whatever it is rather
you echo that but since for me it's
confusing already whether or not it's a
lion or a dragon and then you add that
flame breath on top is just not helping
you right now right and you know one
thing I want to point out is all the
other submissions had the lion facing
forward and I'm just thinking of my own
memory
I don't normally see lines represented
from the side from a profile very much
mm-hmm and just in like a lot of
historical stuff that I've seen so it's
it's interesting so maybe that's another
reason why it's hard to read actually in
sigils the lion is most of the times
looking to the left or right about the
Griffin right the Griffin has a lion's
head so speaking of that now you could
probably have one of the lines claws out
front with this arm right in in lieu of
the fire breath right I think that would
look really cool because it's very
strong it's like stand back because I'm
gonna claw you and I'm gonna destroy you
right so maybe there's an element in
there that you can throw in I think that
would look good so then you would have
to scoot the line over to the right to
create room for the claw and then you
can put it in there and I think that
would be great
so those are my little pieces of advice
or critique for you can tell
I'm pretty sure by the time this episode
airs you already have fixed it because
you're that good in that fast Joe coming
up climbing goal a and then in the chat
says Super Saiyan Lannisters well let's
say that Super Saiyan Lannisters what is
saying from Dragon Ball Z I go super
saiyan they get the golden hair in it
that's the shape you guys we're mixing
all kinds of references now we're doing
anime manga and mixing it with Game of
Thrones somebody is happy right now
somebody Kento is a new designer from
what I'm looking at so he's a graphic
designer in Japan I believe I've been he
had more screens or no that's okay
because I can't cut away from my deck
right now right because I would like to
look at that Kento good job yeah good
job there's a future for you in the
future who I get no sort of fact I got
no okay maybe only like listens in for
his bits of wisdom and wit crystal got
Jack okay next up well how old in here
perfect because it's time to talk about
how start a winter winter is coming okay
hopefully how start one of my faves okay
here we go
the wolf also had many the dire wolf I
should say the dire wolf not just
regular wolf had many many submissions
to but you've got cold down to just a
handful so here's the mission number one
it's the howling dire wolf from who
heared up from legs from Kenta Yoshida
against again it's a monster it's a
monster
what the heck but maybe if we look
closely he just cut the wolf's head and
put it on the lion and had it here no
I'm just kidding I'm sure he did not do
that
so kento's kind of run the whole gamut
different styles and asked him ways of
rendering he really yeah this is how you
show this is how you flex you guys this
is a massive flex on us right now
no these were all from Kento beforehand
no because we do you know when we were
judging these levels we don't read the
names we were just looking on a short
stack and we're looking at thumbnails
super tiny so it's probably about 25% of
the shape so we were looking from afar
to
see what's gonna catch our eye first if
it was worth click on then we click in
but even when we click in like my eyes
are squinting right now and I can't even
see the the name at all so we're just
basing it completely off of merit as it
should be as it should be right we
should be able to decide from afar from
a thumbnail size is it a good markers or
not can we read it does it convey the
house virtues it's it's the proper
animal all those kinds of things we're
making those decisions and you guys need
to know that because sometimes we can
zoom into our own drawings like super
super tight mm-hm and think oh this is
genius and then you zoom out you're like
oh my gosh all the negative spaces are
filling in because at this scale none of
it reads and it's important to be able
to do that right I did notice in case
Erin you were wondering Kendall did have
a lot of submissions but in terms of us
selecting we don't look at that at all
right all right so gasps all you want
let's get back into the critique it's
it's using the shape really well I think
because it's taking up this kind of
diagonal prominence with the legs in the
back and the arms up front the front
legs right and in the tail out there I
think it's really cool I think the
negative shapes in here aren't great
they feel fussy and detailed right so I
would like to have you possibly work on
that Matthew did you read something
funny in the chats
yeah I'm giggling here just cuz a lot of
people are saying kento is hired
Tevin Morris's kento is like a warg here
he's controlling you the ward okay okay
the wards controlling you and me give
him a job hashtag hire Kento he only has
19 followers on Instagram so you guys
check out kento's work on Instagram it's
at ky underscore logo yeah show him some
love yeah he's got a bunch of these
sigils that he did for the show on his
Instagram that's probably all of them
because I'm gonna need things in the
enter I don't know but I see three six
eight eight of his nineteen posts yeah I
think so I think so this is really great
okay let's move on okay this is the last
one from House Stark this is from Newton
Nutan okay at first you look at this
like winter is coming yeah it looks like
a snowflake mm-hmm but wait there's more
if you look at it carefully it's the
face of a direwolf yeah
that's pretty clever but I have to work
really hard at that I think do you
that's my son once I do yeah do you
Ricky no I think it's actually a good
balance between the two way I saw it
right away
I like this snowflake I like the snow
and then the direwolf in there I really
like how the nostril is treated the nose
of the direwolf here coming down so it
seems like a very tricky puzzle to
figure out and solve so for that reason
you know I'm I'm intrigued by that as a
designer just looking at this like wow
how did this person solve this puzzle so
it's two things that they smash together
very well I think yeah so from a couple
hundred feet away on the battlefield you
like winter's coming here it is the
snowflakes coming at me and then when
you're about to die and somebody's gonna
smash that shield into your face like
it's a dark scene I'm saying Ricky
before I die it's a wolf so I'm gonna
nitpick a little bit here the eyes of
the wolf was probably really where if
you just refine that a little bit will
let people know that's a wolf okay I
also feel like it could be scooted down
a skosh because the shape above the eye
is really tiny the gray shape and you
have to be mindful of those things I
don't think it's gonna hurt legibility
at all if you just scooted them down so
there was a little bit more gray above
it negative space and that's it
otherwise well done and this one is not
by kento just letting you guys know you
can tell this is my new tooth Newton
alright house Martell unbowed unbent and
broke in love this house okay house
Martell we only have one submission that
made the final selection here and this
is from Ricky Pedro de Silva betta Pedro
de Silva Peeta excellent all right Pedro
de Silva Peeta
okay and what what is their house is
like a son
with a spear that's what I'm saying I
think you have it on the slide before no
no see Dorn was only something something
banisters coat-of-arms the coat-of-arms
is a gold spear piercing a red Sun on a
golden background hmm and that's models
okay so a gold spear piercing a red Sun
mm-hmm that kind of looks like a gold
spear piercing a red Sun I think there's
some really cool parts there's some
really interesting fragmented shapes
that are jetting out from the center and
some squealy things coming out too to
show the sunrays and I think that's
really good I guess my problem here is i
think it's just missing that little I
don't know Genesee quad something to
make it really special
Matthew mm-hmm and also a little kind of
nitpicky thing here I'm not sure and
because I don't wanna lose my eyesight
just putting my face up to the screen
but I think it's important to in the
triangular shapes that are jutting out
with a curved edge and I think is a
straight edge mm-hmm whereas the outer
sunrays are on a curved edge I think
yeah tell I think you're right I can't
tell so we're just talking at the base
of the race right like all of those rays
they're all flat versus the circular
shape that they're butted up next to so
it's creating just some weird tension
there that's not resolved yet and I
think those are small details that will
definitely add up in the compound effect
of how we reveal this and how we look at
this and I think another thing in terms
of the negative space of how things are
close to each other I don't particularly
like how all the points are close to the
edge of the crest I feel like that it's
also creating some unusual tension there
like the point of the spear at the very
bottom I know what you did it but it for
some reason it's not creating a pleasant
tension for me it's it's creating it's
just a little awkward I know what it is
I think you're saying Pedro is trapped
in no-man's land
mm-hmm or no person's land where if
you're gonna get that close just break
the edge or stay away from it it's just
really in an uncomfortable like are you
gonna do it or not right
stab it or don't write a couple other
little tips here like I said before it's
very hard to make things look the men
you know when they're very flat and
graphic however with the illusion of
shadow you can actually give things a
dimensional quality so for example the
Sun if it's the source of light then
things radio rating it away from the Sun
it would cast a little bit of shadow so
at the bottom of the spear underneath
the circular shape right ahead of the
spear if he curved that line downwards
instead of upwards it would feel as if
that ball casted a shape or a shadow
onto the sphere itself right and if you
curve the shadows or the shape of the
spirit it'll make it look like a rod
instead of a two-dimensional piece of
paper so those little things will
actually add quite a little bit in terms
of the illusion same thing when the
spear penetrates through the Sun from
the top down it's cutting in in a very
flat way if you round off the bottom of
that you'll feel like the Sun has
dimension and this beer has dimension
mm-hmm you guys understood that yeah
it's hard without the illustration on
top but it it has a lot of potential
what do you mean like if I can't draw on
top of this yeah if you were to draw on
top then it would help but okay I know
young man who probably can help me young
man
well I wouldn't say young man who could
help me Ricky leans right in chairs like
he's not talking to me Ricky can you
load this one up for me I can do it from
all from my computer I'll send it over
there to here Yeltsin
okay I don't know how to do any that
technology stuff I'll hop in it ya know
a different young man's gonna help me
Ricky oh that's your opportunity to be
called young man okay house Tully family
duty and honor not a ton of submissions
only a couple but it's really tricky to
do a fish what kind of fish is a trout
with red stripes and blue okay and it's
models family duty and honor okay this
one comes from Jeff Brown this is a
really interesting and abstract
representation of a fish and waves and
in a way that just really caught my eye
I cut my eye to eye like this this is
the one that stood out and you know a
lot of the submissions weren't this very
vivid and typed yes hello yes those like
bold contrast it's very minimal like
it's not trying to take up all the space
but just the balance of negative and
positive space here drew my eyes so the
power of negative space can be very
useful where I know a lot of the
feedback I've been giving earlier like
how to maximize and utilize the spaces
the opposite where they're using
something that's a little bit more
petite and small yet it draws your eye
in just as as well yes I have some
technical issues but let me just talk
about all that's good super simple super
graphic I feel like it's powerful and
and it feels like the trout it's about
to breach the water with its fin up on
the top it's at a dorsal fin on the top
sure people went to college I didn't
take marine biology I'm sorry just a
name a fish part you have to hit be a
marine biologist I mean we can extreme
there geez I would be colleges I'm sure
we needed you I need a call a man
okay anyways the little nitpicky bits
here is the house colors are red white
and blue so I would have liked to have
seen a little bit of the red in there
not a lot but just a little bit the
other part is you see the space between
the two waves at the ends they seem
thicker visually yeah then in the middle
and I think for me it'll just mid not
much nicer if it was equidistant excuse
me all the way through okay so that's
that let me move on to house Bolton
house Bolton our blades are sharp and
their symbol is the flayed man
basically for whatever reason they has a
month session with skinning people alive
and hanging it up on an X hanging them
up on an X this is not one of the great
houses but it's okay we're flexible like
that so here we go this is what the
flayed man this is from Marcus hello
yeah so there's something dude oh yeah
have you seen - Oh Ricky yeah okay so
you know yeah the flayed man yeah okay
so a couple things about this first of
all I really appreciate the illustration
and for whatever reason the line work
and the repeating patterns and there's
somewhat equidistant has a very calming
cool effect and and it feels also like
the veins of the lines of the body once
the skin has been peeled off so for that
I quite like this I also like that the
arms have been chopped off and there's
blood dripping from the neck and the
arms and there's a little bit of a skull
pattern in the center of the chest and
and the six pass so this is a very fit
dead person everybody on the show is
pretty fit yeah me but I guess you
peeled off my skin would you also peel
off the flat late the fat hair I
probably look like this if I
play - so there is some benefit to being
flayed alive you just look really good
all right so that's the mark using a
couple of colors here now we didn't want
to spend too much time on this but this
was a very unique thing I think again we
probably needed scooch this up a little
bit north and I understand why you don't
draw the rest of the body but part of
the flayed man is that X symbol because
they're hung on those correct bosses you
know yeah yeah Thank You Matthew okay so
let's move on then yeah White Walkers
whoo White Walkers not even a great
house let somebody decide to do the
White Walkers they have no motto they
have no symbol cuz they're just a band
of dead zombies right they're the band
of then dead and they would never make a
symbol because you see them you don't
need to know who the enemy is
it's pretty clear because they're all
like rotting flesh right and skull face
yeah this wasn't one of the ones that we
had listed but I think they they broke
the rule here but that's okay because of
the mark actually okay turned out my own
pretty deep yeah so this is from math
palma yep we do we say math or math or
make math a little Lisp in there math
math palma may be short for matthew now
palma good job on this we see the eye we
see that blue eye and the small iris and
it's just kind of in an almond shape
it's pretty cool and then we see these
lines around their faces which is also
kind of part of the design of the lights
right mm-hmm so it's pretty cool yeah
it's kind of like the I think they are
like frozen muscle fibers or something
on their faces so that's why I kind of
has these these ridges along the eye so
it's it's very intense looking I mean I
know they're the the main bad guys in
the show when you look at this that it
definitely conveys that they feel little
treacherous it makes me feel
uncomfortable I think whenever an eye is
looking at you this directly yeah does
make you uncomfortable what makes me
feel uncomfortable is dishes one eye
right because it's like the Eye of
Sauron yeah and there's something that's
throwing me off
and I don't know if you want to
illustrate the whole face but I think
having two eyes or something else in
there would have been really cool I
think as a standalone element it's
really beautiful it's well drawn and I
like it
I would also probably wear this on a
t-shirt so good job on that it's just in
terms of like a mark for the
house maybe I'm just quibbling about
little details here mm-hmm okay before
we reveal to you our pick for the top
five I want to remind you guys the
criteria in which we use we pick it
based on is it legible is it unique is
it appropriate to the house and it's a
bold can we see it from far away and I'm
not gonna tell you who won I'm gonna go
to my screen now and work on some things
let's see how this goes so I plan on
doing some draw overs on my iPad and
then I'm also going to jump into
illustrator and see if I can't in
somewhat real-time show you guys a
couple things in Illustrator okay and
this is probably a good time for us to
maybe read some questions or prompt the
audience to say or do something funny
maybe
does anybody have any good questions ask
the audience is done questions you don't
have to have good questions yeah do we
have a problem for them at all no and
well that's what I asked you guys while
I prepare okay yeah so Chris well Chris
will go there let's see I'm just real
I'm going there how do I pick her to
grab this color I mean everybody's just
okay Darrin by design said I like this
one
Kent for the kento for the win a lot of
people want us to hire kento so I think
you guys should probably hop I was doing
I'm doing it as soon as I got there yep
I'm gonna drop some value-based pricing
on you ready Chris how much is this
worth to you kento jumped up to forty
three followers a little bit yeah I
think I think that's just about it does
I want to ask the audience who's their
favorite they can rewind and go back and
and let us know we have it numbered here
so if you guys go back and let us know
which one was your favorite and see if
that matches up with Chris and/or
Matthews top five so I think that's the
prompt yeah it was what was everybody's
favorite one of the ones we showed so
far for sure yeah and there were you
know on a say thank you everyone for
submitting us dozens of great entries
thank you
everybody worked really hard so I like
that yeah there was some really great
entries across the board obviously we
didn't go over 50 today otherwise this
would be a three hour five hour
livestream and I think we would all get
a little angry over there which I know
it's our local news we're trying
technically I don't want to see that
this lasts so hang in there guys yeah
and have good news for everybody if you
watched yesterday's livestream with Gary
Vaynerchuk Gary Vee yeah thank you it's
like what is he doing okay so if you
guys watch that and you wanted to hear
more specific advice and ideas that are
on creativity and design here's the good
news I tweeted Gary this morning it said
I regret not asking more design related
questions
something that Matthew said yeah we
should have gotten into that earlier
well he's agreed to come back on the
show you guys so stay tuned for that
yeah he's a good guy yeah okay so let's
jump into my iPad now guys let's see
what happens here there we are and we're
here and I'm gonna talk a little bit
about how to create those shadow shapes
that we were talking about so let me
somebody messed around with my brushes I
think pasady bleed so Chris is on his
iPad in procreate yep I don't want it's
in a technical and I want people are
Matthew sorry yeah I was gonna say that
I know Chris doesn't use procreate a
whole lot he use it for little draw
overs and sometimes when he's sketching
his ideas but he you know I know his
tool of choice for something like this
is probably Photoshop just because he
knows where all the tools are so if you
see him bumbling around it's just
because he doesn't use it this in depth
okay yeah would be nice I'm painting in
here this is spear that we talked about
right so you can I can zoom in I believe
to help you guys out there a little bit
so I'm trying to create that illusion so
when I talked about the cash out
underneath the ball here if I round off
the corners I try to create a little
dimension with that you see what I'm
saying there it's not a huge thing I
probably need to paint back some of this
mm-hmm
where would I paint it Matthew you
talking about the top of the sphere yeah
as the spear penetrates this and I think
I created a lay here so I can turn it on
and off so you guys can see before it's
got this super sharp flat
right there you guys can see that and
then when I turn it back on I'm just
rounding it off a little bit so that you
can see that it's dimensional and you
got on both ends okay so go ahead
Matthew yeah it's gonna say yeah that's
very interesting just by curving the
shadow there the implied lighting then
you all of a sudden get this round sense
of depth right that it's a cylinder
there or and so that definitely helps a
lot and I think throughout this when
we're looking a lot of the flat graphic
submissions mm-hmm definitely a lot of
them could have benefited for some of
this implied lighting or graphic
lighting yeah and I'm seeing now I feel
like all the bottom edges of these
shapes now are just flat lines Matthew
and rotate it around right and that's
where I think you need to just cut those
so that they're circular so they follow
that shape another thing I want to point
out here I'm gonna switch in colors here
is this is that we have this dimension
we have this dimension we have this and
we have a lot of very similar things and
we have to just be very careful about
how those elements are repeating and how
they build a cohesive whole and then we
have this dimension here which is also
kind of odd so again maybe maybe we just
need to vary things a little bit less so
I'm gonna try and pick this color I'm
not an expert user of this stuff guys
okay
then I wouldn't bring this back down a
little bit there so that you're not
adding another shape in there it's just
too many shapes okay and we have to be
mindful of the thickness of the spear
compared to the Rays so I think maybe
making a little bit thicker would have
helped whatever I'm just trying to
destroy the design right now right
mm-hmm so that's we have to be mindful
of dimensions that's all not to create
too many different things right so Chris
is trying to rebalance that while he's
doing that I want to answer a couple of
questions on this stream let's see are
we gonna be choosing from the your top
five from the ones we were shown today
yes yes so that was a question so that
was one question and these are all from
the top 50 there was another question in
here let's see this is from TQ design
services are there any good illustrator
resources online for a newbie and if you
look in the description of
our show today there's something there
with a link and it says be boiled Emmy
slash the future this is our buddy Dan
Dan Scott he's a really good instructor
when it comes to fundamentals of the
tools so if you want to learn Photoshop
if you want to learn illustrator if you
use our link there you could check out
his courses they're relatively
inexpensive and he's really good fun and
engaging and you're gonna see him on a
future episode here on the Academy
probably next week or the following week
so you can get a taste of what he does
his teaching style but I highly
recommend him he's a really nice guy and
he knows his tools he I was watching a
tutorial that he was making for us and I
learned so many things that I didn't
know about illustrator so that just goes
to show how how good he is and how
up-to-date he stays with the tool so
check that out in the description I'm
gonna just drop that it's in the chat
it's already in the chat I was in the
chat job that's a job so I'm playing
around here with adding a little bit of
detail so that we have some variation so
it doesn't feel as flat as it was I
don't know if I'm making it better but I
just a lot of times people watch the
show and I call what is he doing this is
a joke oh and what I'm doing just I'm
just trying to show you different ways
of working through a problem I'm not
telling you that in minutes that I can
solve and make everything better
that's not how design works and we all
know that so I think people that are
true fans of the show understand this as
a concept and I'm trying to create
illusion right I'm just creating a
little bit of more dimension it looks
like it's hotter like the Sun is hotter
when you add these little flourishes to
me so you're saying I make things hotter
no I'm saying the Sun looks warmer like
these and you know I know even though
you're just drawing it with the Apple
pencil here these little imperfections
actually give it a lot of character yeah
I like it that things are not ending
perfectly flatter perfectly straight
these things actually add a bit of
character so that's also another thing
to consider as you guys design these
things yeah so I I'm not gonna add too
much to it right because I don't want to
make it too complicated
you could easily also go in and add a
little tip here if you wanted to you
kind of extend that idea but I think now
I'm getting too fussy with it right and
I just think having some of those shapes
in there is all I wanted to do
and if I knew how to use this better I
would have scaled to shape down so that
Matthews a little happier with it not
coming all the way to the edge right but
I'm just not that talented with
appropriate yeah and what Chris is doing
here too you could repeat that same
thing on that tip of the spear to give
that a little bit more dimension to like
those are little things that we can
extend out but I'm starting to get angry
so let's move on to the so Matthews
using the scapegoat freeing that's for
but it's really Matthew who's really
super hungry and look I learned how to
pick colors Matthew look at that so I
use the white you know whatever and I
could make the brush a little bit bigger
so here's the thing I'm gonna switch
over to my desktop now but before before
aaron cuts to let me just change some my
settings okay mm-hmm Matthew can fill in
yeah so just to recap this protecting
you pull that back up on screen the the
reason why Chris brought this one up is
that both of us thought that this had a
lot of potential we like how this
particular designer used up the space
here we had some issues with that I and
the crescent moon and just the overall
delivery of what was in the shape here
but we thought it had so much potential
because of how unusual and how beautiful
all of these curved lines are kind of
coming together so we thought the
technique and their approach is really
good but the execution could use a
little bit of work so I think Chris was
gonna bring this in and do a little bit
of tweaking to it to see if we could
improve the ability so the first thing
that I notice is we don't need all this
extra stuff on this right and that the
the shape of the head feels a little bit
like an eagle for me for some reason I
wasn't sure so let's let's go and jump
to my desktop right now hopefully I'm
not revealing anything weird on my
machine but I just typed in Falcon head
and what I noticed is that it's got a
pretty pronounced upper beef that hooks
down in some more so than others like
this one it says it's a Falcon head
majestic HD stock look how far that
drops down and the way it's shaped right
it almost looks like a the bottom part
of a J the bowl of the J or the arm or
the leg of the J and then you look back
at the mark that you created here it's
not like that at all and it's I think
it's important and I'm not saying I'm a
naturalist that I know birds and things
I can spot them from afar but
we want to make sure that's true to that
notice also the eye of the bird the eye
the bird is really big relative to the
scale of the head
any day now Aaron will cut to this and
then see it so look at this bird's eye
look how big that sucker is right so
it's missing certain qualities and if
you're gonna draw a profile of a bird
let's not just try to do with any bird
so there's some things in there so what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna attempt to do I
should say now going back to the iPad
here see if I can do this I want to
erase some of this stuff okay so I'm
just gonna start painting over it
because I want to get rid of all that
Chuck
mm-hmm and I hopefully have been smart
about creating a layer yes I have well I
probably should have just duplicated the
layer this is already much nicer I think
that good Matthew I just erased but
kinda it's what's cool about this once
you did that reduction now I could see
the bird and it almost feels like the
wing extending out on the bottom part of
it mm-hmm it feels like the the bird's
shoulder and the wings so now all of a
sudden it becomes super legible as to
what it is I think that moon was the
thing that was reading like an eye that
was really throwing me off right but now
just simple simplifying definitely help
yes so the position of the eye is a
little bit off relative to my reference
here right so there's a couple other
things that we gonna do if Matthew like
me getting rid of stuff I'm gonna get
rid of more stuff let's see what happens
here so before I'm gonna mark this up no
I'm gonna just say like the bottom part
of the throat here I'm gonna erase this
just for a little bit and see what
happens I think could have transitioned
a little bit differently come on
transition down here mm-hmm
so though we don't have a funny throat
right
so I'm gonna do that I'm doing my best
to try and keep this a mono stroke thing
and not add thick's and Thins because
that'll change the complexion so there's
that part I think what I want to do is
change the beak so that comes out and it
hooks down and it comes back over a
little bit more mm-hmm and then I think
I want to move this I over here and make
it a little bit bigger like that mm-hmm
okay so let me let me see what happens
when I do that cool I just want to call
out I think
Lorcan is on the in the stream right now
thank you so much for submitting this
and sending us your files we ended up
not using the illustrator file that you
sent but we're just drawing over the
submission anyway I think what is more
instructive if I just do it fast like
this right yeah fast and sloppy we're
not trying to spend two hours here just
getting ideas skits that's so
inappropriate that's out of it I don't
even know what that means Matthew I have
no idea Matthew is no longer allowed to
have the controls of the of the iPad for
the the Pitti trumpet that's what the
sound effect this call just kidding but
so you just keep drawing here and I
think I want to just bring it down and
then bring it back up right and then I
think has a jaw in here somewhere so I
want to bring it back up and then bring
it over a little bit maybe mm-hmm yeah
it's looking that Falcons looking pretty
mean trying to give it a little edge you
know what's cool about this as we as
you're making these adjustments now it
feels like the head is protruding
forward like it's coming forward in
space yeah so I really like that part so
this thing you were previously you had a
swirl and it was kind of bringing you to
the center of the frame now it feels
like this nice offset thing where the
head is moving forward and the wings are
moving back so it has this nice depth to
it I think this is a much better use of
the space in there mm-hmm I know it's
just a little bit sloppy but if you guys
can see this like it's starting to have
a really nice effect for me now I'm
gonna say that this is kind of like
where I want to leave this let me make
another layer here before we spend too
much time
this is there's a couple other ideas I
would try if I were really trying to
make this great right so I I could try
to bring this wing down and bring
another wing up here so that he's
starting to show a shape of the wing but
I don't know if I had those kind of
skills right now right mm-hmm
so let me just try and do it really
right bold and fast here and the other
part of a house maybe I don't know right
there's detail and contrast right so we
have one side of it Matthew which is
really bold and simple and the other
side has some detail right that the head
separates from the wing right so that
would go back you know one thing that I
wanted to call out if we had more time
on this this is House Arryn and the
other part of it is the crescent moon we
could play instead of that weird eye
right below the beat oh I got a solution
for that but keep going yeah I was gonna
say the crescent moon could be the eye
of the bird so that there is still those
two reads that are there mm-hmm but that
could be one way where you fold that in
when I just give it a little crescent
moon highlight right oh that's terrible
they made a cool mean bird like like too
friendly right so that's it I don't mean
to make a logo for the US Olympic team
but with the red and blue but that's
that's kind of what I was thinking there
okay so I will mark up one more and then
we'll probably jump in Illustrator
hopefully depending on Matthews appetite
who will see so I'm gonna mark on top of
this and let us know you guys in the
comments below if you like the markups
and if it makes talking about design a
little bit easier to follow along yeah
this is normally a we don't go this long
on these streams typically and normally
we have stuff like on local therapy
which you guys have watched before where
usually we have our designers prepare
stuff ahead of time this one we're
trying to do real time we're trying to
talk to these about these things very
openly and transparently so that you
understand mine and Chris's thought
process as we evaluate and look at these
things and some of the things that we
would tweak knowing where we came from
so so let's get into it yeah right yeah
okay so the first thing that Matthew and
I talked about it's get rid of this part
of the tail I don't think you need that
so what I would think we can do is just
do the wing like this right and as I get
more comfortable with this I'd sorry I'm
starting to get a feel for how to spin
works Matthew mm-hmm right and so this
little part at the bottom which you
can't see because I'm hovering over but
I'm gonna drop for you right now so I
think we could probably end it a little
earlier mm-hmm so the body separates
from that yeah I like that close back up
all right so do this and I think the jaw
maybe oh yeah I like that
right so the rest of it can stay the way
it is so I think by having the wing up
here mm-hmm
then that way it creates the shape
implies the shape that's here without it
completing the circle and I don't think
that's necessary right and what I like
about this too is you know as you're
just quickly drawing the curves there I
like that like the top of the head you
added like a little bit more of a ramp
in the curve it adds a little bit more
movement in the piece of the more you
have these expressive curves where
they're kind of like almost if you
continued it it would fold over on
itself eventually like those little
wispy lines helps create a lot of
dynamic movement when you're looking at
something like this then what I would do
is let's see if I can simulate this for
the details of the wing and also I would
to go light here that would get thick
here mm-hmm
then go thin here right and just reduce
that down so thin thick thin too thick
right and then create movement right so
for this little detail again thin too
thick mm-hmm then thin it out and maybe
not even do both sides of that because I
want to get rid of detail I don't think
we need all that stuff so same here then
too thick and then just a little arrows
pointing and that's all I think it needs
okay and then later on we're going to
cut some shapes into here to show you
guys what the heck I was talking about
earlier about creating the illusion of
space and form okay having said that
Matthew you can hang in there for
another five to ten minutes should we
hang in there you guys or should we just
go to lunch and call it today no I think
we should reveal the tough five okay are
people also super angry themselves no
there's 260 watching if you want me real
the top five or you want me to do the
illustrator demo I want you to reveal
the top five so we're closing out then
okay we're closing out is that what
you're saying yeah so no demo all right
no demo some other time well I don't
want to listen to Ricky so I've got no
more anyways no that's right Ricky's
also hangry that's why he's we're all
let me get my palette where's my palette
well if I can't find my palettes game
over right now it's Game of Thrones No
and James James Betts is in the live
stream right now he's had cheers for the
feedback totally agree
oh there's Kento can't tell you [ __ ] hey
so are you a man or a woman it doesn't
really matter to us but I'm just curious
yeah another guy said his name was Ken
tone he was from Japan he said he was a
guy so I'm gonna assume properties Toby
yeah I want to read this from kento
Yoshida he says hello the future team
thank you so much for the critique it's
so inspiring yeah I'll make the changes
to the sigils based off of the critique
okay thank you okay so here's what I'm
gonna do guys let's jump to my screen
I'm not gonna do the full-blown thing
this is gonna be those cooking shows
where you get to see some of it right so
here's the original right and we're
already marching up over there so what I
did was who sent me this file again
James James Betts okay I just took your
file and convert it into guides right so
one thing I'm gonna give you guys a hot
tip you could go to command K and you go
to your guides this is kind of set up by
default as a really bright blue color
and super hard to see so all you do now
that you can pick any color just drag it
to be a little bit darker blue so that's
what I did there and I changed it from
lines and dots because lines can also be
very overpowering when it comes to this
kind of stuff I just want you guys know
about that anyway so I've already gone
and started drawing some things so I
just went in here and started drawing
some shapes so this should reflect the
ideas I was talking about now you might
say like shouldn't this be with perfect
geometry and yes you could instead of
just drawing it freehand like the way
I've done it right
right and and that's probably the
smarter way to do it but just in the
interest of time so I'm just looking at
how these shapes taper in and out right
yeah so here because I hadn't drawn this
before we can play around with the head
because Matthew liked a more pronounced
brow right and what we're looking for is
a little bit more movement a little bit
more curvature mm-hm so I'm pretty
pretty smooth adept at using the pen so
this is pretty easy to do for me but
those you guys that need some practice
there's a great online tool it's the
master the pen tool game right and you
can do that
now I'm gonna explain a couple things
historically or not historically
traditionally what I would do is I would
bring the body down and draw that and
start intersecting shapes instead of
just trying to complete it because what
happens is this line here sometimes will
not optically connect with this line
right so really I should detach these
two things which I can do right now
where's my scissor tool I think it's in
here this is a tool I can just cut it
right here boom and then I'm gonna hide
this part just for a second so you guys
can see so I'm gonna bring back my pen
tool which is P and then drag it down
here and then complete this shape any
which way that I want that way I know
that optically it's one smooth
continuous part of the body nice okay
the other thing that I probably want to
do and we have to make a decision do we
want to terminate an end on a hard edge
here or do we roll smoothly right back
into the bottom of the circle what do
you think Matthew tell me I'll do it I'm
sorry I was paying until you see the
stream you see this intersection right
here yes should it be a hard cut or
should I try to roll off the bottom of
this right back into the bottom of the
circle ooh
let's let her let let's let it roll into
the bottom of the circle k so then what
I need to do is I need to add another
anchor point here which I will and then
I'll take this and I move it to the
bottom of the circle and I'm gonna zoom
in here so you guys can see this a
little bit better the way that you make
it perfectly transition into the bottom
of the circle is these handles have to
be tangent to that circle mm-hmm so if
it's not tangent to it it won't smooth
smoothly and you get a little kink there
okay mm-hmm so let's assume that that's
as smooth as I'm gonna be able to make
it for the show okay so that's Oh Xena
I'm jacking it up already right because
now the handles are compete yeah because
they're Sara fighting each other right
okay so this one is too far right okay I
know Chris is you know yeah it's just
like the less points you have to form
your curves the more perfect they're
going to be yep so what we can do is
after we're done here we can use the
shape builder one thing I want to do is
just make sure everything intersects and
that way we can do the shape builder and
we can do this part of the of the body
right so for right now right now I'm
gonna show you just some quick tips and
I'm gonna finish this neck and the way
that I know where to put these anchor
points is I think about a circle and the
circle has four anchor points so on the
top one a middle and one inside that's
I'm doing there so this one also has a
really nice transition down yeah over
shadow right there so when I'm do is
hard and then do this
alright curve yep yeah so I'm not gonna
finish the rest of the body of this
dragon right let me just do it over here
okay so we can draw this wing separately
and bring those two together okay mm-hmm
so I think I have most of the shapes
that I want I'm going to do one more
thing here I lied I'm gonna just go for
it
you guys hang in there hungry I'm
leaning in time just wait
hopefully I hook you with the learning
part and then you don't think about the
food that you're not eating all right
okay
so I'll do this here again we're I
should snap a guide to make sure that
this is centered right that this is the
middle point and these are equidistant
but in the interest of time in the demo
so now I have those three shapes
that's all crossing now I believe I can
go ahead and do the shape builder thing
okay which everybody should know at this
point I select all these things I think
it's called shift em right there shift
him so every time you hover over a tool
try to master and remember the keyboard
shortcuts that's how you become a power
user okay so if I draw over this and I
select this and it's like this and I
take this parts and I'm kind of done now
I'm gonna hold down - or I'm sorry on
the Mac I don't know what it is on the
PC I'm sorry not hating on PC I just
don't know okay and I'm gonna get rid of
these parts mm-hmm now I should have all
the shapes that I need okay nope dad I
screw up somehow go back to chef m I'm
gonna get rid of this mm-hmm
yeah I think I have all these things
right I have some weird yeah I don't
know it's not question about doing that
that's it it's okay anyway so now I can
take this I'm gonna hit shift X and I'm
gonna make it like that I'm gonna hide
those guides and now we can see that we
have some shapes to work with we don't
need these little bits here I could
delete those now and now I'm starting to
realize a couple things one is I think I
need to bring this shape in tighter so
we can complete the circle right but
that's that's what I would start to do
right there okay I'm gonna delete this
because we don't need this this is a
horrible drawing right you guys get that
it's not great but the fact that I think
if you just squint at it and if you look
at how it's asymmetrical how its
utilizing
the space and how your eye is still
completing the circle even though the
points are not connecting I think that
was the whole point of this exercise is
just to show you guys how you can offset
stuff how you can add a little bit more
dimension and how you can visually still
create these fun wispy elements that
create a lot of movement within the
shape of this and even looking at this
as one color which is Chris's tip to all
of you guys who started the challenge
start with black and white because if
that reads that means you know that your
contrast your silhouette is very strong
and it's very good and so before you add
all the lines and the details and the
textures and the colors your silhouette
has to be good first yeah so some of you
guys don't know this but I'm going to
show you really quick tip here I should
have done this when I still have the
circle is to define the center point of
the circle maybe I'll get lucky right
now and just like this there it is I got
lucky let's go there so I'm gonna turn
my snap to point on view guide snap to
point I'm gonna snap this down and it
should just touch that and there we go
that's the center of the circle and
that's really important in order for me
to draw this part right here okay I'm
gonna show you guys how to draw that
part really really fast so typically you
start at the top so if you have the
pencil hit P for pen tool and I think
it's straight now do we want it to be
curved or we want it to be straight
Matthew that's a good question
just say one I'll do it I want it to be
curved okay you wanted to curve so I'm
gonna go like this I'm gonna go up like
that so there's a little curvature I'm
gonna hook it back and then I'm gonna do
this okay so then it has a little kind
of curvature to it right mm-hmm I like
that okay now it intersects the circle
perfectly which my thing doesn't but the
trick I wanted to show you oh I guess I
can help out whoever drew the sudden
logo before right he's if I take a
circle from the center here and I draw
it out to clip it right where it needs
to be I'm gonna hit shift X to change
that okay so I'm gonna take this and I'm
a skillet up from the center sorry guys
if I'm moving really fast for you no
this is great okay because you're I
could come still hungry Chris okay so
there this way I can get a perfect cut
that's circular okay I'll probably need
to make some adjustments so now I can do
this again I can hit shift M
and just keep this part and then get rid
of all this other part okay there I
think this time it'll work and hit shift
X I need to do it demo fail again okay
there it is right so now I'm gonna take
this sucker and I'm gonna hit R for
rotation and I'm hold down the option
key I'm gonna plant the anchor point
right here holding down option click
once sorry
click once and I'm gonna take this and
rotate it while holding down the option
key which will copy it right and now I
hit command D alright now I realize I
messed up because I didn't pull it far
enough okay the anchor point is still
there we rotate it and I'm gonna end it
right there and while holding down
option and how I hit command D wow
that's so cool so you guys can do this
and it should be perfect so I'm just
gonna heat I'm still holding on D and
it's running around the track and it's
gonna Wow
so if you guys want to do that and it's
really simple obviously I didn't find a
center point cuz look at it it's got
thicker on the right side here and I'm
gonna show you one last little trick
here in terms of creating some of these
interesting elements right so here I'm
gonna take the pen tool I'm gonna draw
up probably put a point here point down
here point up here and then I'm gonna
finish off one right around here okay
now assuming that that followed that
really well which it doesn't I'm gonna
make this I'm going to shift the colors
by hitting shift X and then I'm gonna
bring that stroke up and go to
properties here and I'm gonna fill it
with a white stroke where's white it's
not white let's assume that's white I'm
not sure it's white okay now I'm gonna
go to the width tool where's that tool
here it is right here so I'm a whole
hover over its shift W with shift the
width so the shift W there I love this I
can then go over here and make this part
a little thicker come on make it thicker
right and then these parts taper ends so
I could make this a little thinner or
thicker and that's all I'm going to do
so that's how you can do it that's the
cheap easy late lazy way to do it you
guys could do it much better but that's
one way
why isn't it good come on so you guys
can go and adjust these parts to your
liking and then you can outline or
offset that and you can really adjust it
but that's how we do that okay so let me
hide that part I've created a
monstrosity here you guys I'm so sorry
and I just wanted to give you guys some
tips on how to draw your vector art a
little bit different okay I think it's
time to announce the winners some
winners
oh don't don't know about my screen yet
I need to do something don't do my
screen yet okay George George George um
goal here we go to the screen here are
the top five finalists to what we're
doing you guys ready Erinn top 5 here we
go number one in no particular order
here are the five that you're gonna be
voting on this is from tej and Kim Teja
Kim good job yeah okay and next up is
this one from good job okay and you guys
before we get to the end obviously we
can only pick five 150 submissions so
they're gonna be bound to be some broken
hearts Adrienne side yeah good job good
job
beautiful work and last but not least I
yes Brown well done guys okay I think I
have more slides to go through but we
gotta get out of this show that's you
need to tell them about what's coming up
next yeah so in terms of voting what's
going to happen is shortly after this
stream later today if you go back to the
shortstack link we're gonna add the
description in the comments or sorry in
the description below you guys can go
back there and you're gonna see the top
five that you can vote on okay so that's
gonna be open through the weekend
through early next week
and at some point next week we're going
to announce the winners of round one
mm-hmm how many points they won for
round one and then we're going to
announce the second challenge challenge
number two right to number dos number
two three-part challenge series which
you guys know is going to be designed at
Ward mark for your chosen house will
give you all the details you guys
whoever wins the entire things going to
win a great set of prize a prize set of
things whatever I'm not speaking clearly
now and we're gonna give stuff to you
guys that's it
this is unofficial design challenge you
guys thanks very much for tuning into
today's show on behalf of the entire
team Matthew and
and Rick K thanks for staying all the
way through the livestream see you guys
next time my name is Chris and don't let
your past define you the features what
you make it see you guys next time
[Music]